I decided to put it all on one bat one
horse and one horse race the Cheltenham
Gold Cup in March 2018
and if that horse won
um I would have won that money back I
had the intention to pay everybody back
if it didn't win it had literally become
a matter of life and death and I was
going to go and kill myself
[Music]
I was one of those people that from a
young age I was obsessed with all sports
I didn't really care what I played as
long as I was playing something and it
was all I was bothered about really it
was all I wanted to do and then it
wasn't until I was 15 when
kind of professional Club started to
take an interest in me and I got put on
the academy at northamptonshire that's
when I thought okay this is this is
really something that that might happen
you eventually ended up going to Durham
University to to play cricket there and
study of course yeah so I was playing
full-time professionally after I left
school
um so I arrived at Durham
um in October 2006 year left on a
contract at northamptonshire and life
was pretty perfect at that point in my
life I'd never placed a bet
um I didn't know much about gambling at
all it wasn't something that anybody in
my family did none of my friends did
didn't have the same kind of access and
exposure that you do now and a few of
the guys that I kind of got in with
early on they were into it it was
something that they did and one Saturday
morning we walked into a betting shop in
in the middle of Durham I sat down in
the bucket chair in front of the machine
I had two pounds in my pocket left over
from the night before and being an
overconfident arrogant slightly naive 19
year old boy there was at the time I put
my two quid in the machine
um I put it on the only number that was
different from all the other screen zero
is the last number to come up and I
thought well the chance of it happening
twice in a row and 12 seconds later two
pounds became 72 pounds and my life
changed forever and that was my first
bet I could always say to people I can't
explain the feeling it gave me because
I'd never had it before and weirdly I'd
never have it again yeah it gave me a
like a rush and Buzz like nothing else
and people talk about drugs that was
definitely my drug
and how did The Habit kind of progress
from this point onwards I guess I was
different to most people at University
because I had a lot more money than most
people because I was being paid to play
cricket I had a student loan like
everybody else a generous mom and dad so
I did have more money and I thought to
myself well I can still afford to do
what everybody else is doing so who
cares if I lose a bit gambling
the only thing about it from an early
stage was it started to take up more and
more of my time and I wasn't always kind
of totally honest about how much I was
doing it I'd go with my mates there'd be
a transparency around that but then I'd
also go two or three times at other
points during the day on my own when
when they didn't realize whilst I was at
Uni in in 2007 my Cricket career ended
and
I found that really difficult
um that moment was was tough it hit me
really hard and I started to gamble more
and more because I had the money the
time it would actually replace sport in
many ways and then when I moved to
London it was a huge turning point
because I'd moved to London I think for
the wrong reasons in many ways because
I'd kind of followed the crowd because I
didn't know what I wanted to do in my
life if I wasn't playing Sport and it
was what all my mates were doing I
thought it's the done thing to move to
London to work in finance to try and
earn as much cash as you possibly can
and a big change in my kind of mindset
was I was previously motivated very much
by sort of success and achievement and
now I was only bothered about money and
I think that was partly because I was
gambling but also because that was the
culture and environment that surrounded
me is what kind of drove made people
taking that in that world and so
actually all I wanted was as much money
as I possibly could
what was the biggest amount you won
during this time period having kind of
received some good news at work being
told that I was getting a promotion a
bit of a pay rise a Christmas bonus all
those things you kind of crave as
somebody in that world I went out with
my mates to to celebrate that night
before I met up with my mates I walked
into the shop and I put the biggest bet
on I'd put on to that point it was a
football accumulator
um there were six matches and two of the
matches there had to be a draw three of
the matches both teams had score and one
of the favorites had to lose I put 500
pounds
on this bet I walked upstairs I started
getting drunk my mates and that night
500 pounds became 34
968 pounds
um and that was the biggest single win
that I'd had and ever would have from
that moment onwards not only did I kind
of feel like I was totally Invincible I
thought it would happen every time I did
it when it doesn't where it doesn't
matter it's banned to happen again at
some point but actually the worst thing
about it was that was when it became
like a drug because now if I didn't win
that amount of money it didn't give me
the same Rush Buzz hit just like a drug
and I wanted that every time I did it so
I started to put more and more every
time I bet bigger Stakes
so I'd keep doing it but also I started
to feel guilty embarrassed ashamed
stupid emotions that I wasn't used to
dealing with and I started to combat
those by drinking even more alcohol
taking drugs and
life just started to spiral in a very
very different direction I never told a
single person in the world that I won
that money that night that was pretty
hard but I also lost it in a few weeks
and when it was gone I wanted it back
started trying to win it back and then
once I'd lost that money I started to
get into debt
um and I get over a short period of time
that changed completely nature of my job
was kind of walking from the office to
the Lloyd's building
um historically I would on the way there
I'd stop going to the shop for 15
minutes and have a bet that now became
times where I'd be in there for maybe
three four hours I wouldn't do what I
was supposed to do I'd then make up a
lie about what had happened and rather
than that happening kind of once a week
it started to happen three four times a
week to every day by that point
um I had four bank loans I had five
credit cards
um I'd missed a couple of months rent
payments uh and financial situation was
starting to become pretty dire to tell
the truth
um
I was starting to really struggle my
mental health although I didn't want to
tell anybody about that of course
um
but yeah financially it wasn't great but
if at that point I'd stopped
it wouldn't have been as bad as it ended
up being that's for sure
I'd put on about three and a half Stone
I had all this debt and I thought what
on Earth are you doing I decided to try
and do something about it and leave
London at first when I first became a
teacher I felt that that was the moment
that gave me the opportunity to stop and
I tried and whilst I still did it I
wasn't doing it all day every day and I
thought I'd crack this problem but then
when the first set of holidays came
along things started to go wrong in my
life
I just started to do it more and more
and eventually
um I would probably spend
75 of my day gambling because I could do
it on my phone there's always a reason
to be on your phone people thought I was
on
WhatsApp social media emails all those
things that people are but I was just
gambling
um and so it meant I could do it whilst
I was teaching it meant I could do it
whilst I was
done whatever else
um and I I just did it all day every day
that's that's not an exaggeration
um it just completely consumed
everything the salary I got paid would
usually last the first or second day of
each month
um and then I'd think well how on Earth
am I gonna
pay off my debts my bills carry on
gambling live afford anything I turn to
Payday Loans I had 23 different bank and
payday loans and then I guess all those
kind of avenues had been exhausted and
it was at that point that I started
turning to individuals
and eventually out of desperation I'd
make decisions at work that I'd regret
forever because I would start to abuse
my position as a teacher I worked in a
private school I wasn't stupid I knew
how wealthy some of these people were
had access to that information and I
started to take advantage of it and and
lie to them
so I'd borrow money off parents of
pupils that I taught I lied to them why
I needed the money they'd like respected
me were worried about me they had the
money to lend me
um I promised to pay them back I didn't
pay a penny back I'd gamble it all away
and when it all came to a head it it
transpired that there were 113 different
individual people that I'd borrowed
money off
ranging from about 75 quid which doesn't
sound too bad up to the best part of 30
000 pounds and I had half a million
pounds worth of pure gambling debt
um that obviously now I'm spending the
rest of my life paying back
and it started to take its toll
um live in this double life was was
exhausting and I I actually knew in my
heart of hearts it wasn't sustainable
there was no way I could kind of keep up
this pretense
essentially that's the call that I was
working at became aware of this scale
and the extent of the problem because
they'd received complaints from all
sorts of different people
and they'd kind of opened up an
investigation and at that point
I knew the consequences were going to be
as bad as they could be I knew that I
was going to lose my house I knew I was
probably going to lose my job there's
nowhere I could carry on being a teacher
there or anywhere else
um and I knew I was potentially facing
kind of criminal conviction I might go
to prison because I knew that I'd fought
I'd been kind of forging signatures on
contracts all sorts of different things
and after kind of receiving that news I
borrowed a sum of money off somebody I'd
already borrowed money from told them a
lie I'm not very proud of I said look
I desperately need 10 000 pounds
but I promise I'll pay you back at the
end of the week and that's because
completely coincidentally it was the
start of the Cheltenham horse racing
Festival the biggest Festival of the
Year my biggest week of the year and I
honestly believed I could turn ten
thousand Pounds into half a million so I
put on a series of kind of speculative
bets and I even I thought had a chance
and I had one bit of luck on the
Thursday that will never ever happen
again when one jockey and trainer won
pretty much every race
uh and the 10 000 pounds that I had
started with
um was suddenly 58 000 pounds I decided
to put it all on one bet one horse in
one horse race the Cheltenham Gold Cup
in March 2018. and if that horse won
um I would have won that money back I
had the intention to pay everybody back
um yes I probably still would have lost
my house and my job but at least I could
have put everyone back and my life could
continue but if it didn't win it had
literally become a matter of life and
death and I was going to go and kill
myself
um and I watched that horse race in a
lesson I had kids sat in front of me
doing work I watched a horse lose by a
few lengths and my whole world came
crashing down
did you reach out to anyone for help at
this point
I'd always seen a way out and at that
point there was no way out as far as I
was concerned I tried to essentially
drink myself into submission taken
overdose of of antidepressants sleeping
pills I even tried to drive my car off
the road in a kind of 48-hour period
before eventually
um arriving at a train station
and was on the verge of of doing the
unthinkable that was in floods tears I
had commuters all around me a lot of
them kind of looking at me some of them
laughing at me thinking what's wrong
with that bloke because I've stood there
in a complete mess in floods of tears
but actually I didn't care because I
felt real the only person I could bring
myself to tell
in a way that I felt
was right was was my best mate in the
world and that's my little brother I
didn't want to call him I didn't want
him to me in the state that I was in
um because I think he might have reacted
differently if he'd heard that so
instead of calling him I sent him a
message I told him what I was about to
do
um unfortunately for me having tried to
call me he then sent me a message and
and that message saved my life he said
look tell me what the problem is talk to
me about it and and I promise I'll try
and help
um and as simple as it sounds that's
what I needed to hear and it's What
stopped me doing it
I took myself home I came clean to my
girlfriend initially and and then my
parents and that was so tough
um but I think one of the things that I
reflect on more than anything else is
that their reaction was so different to
how I thought it was going to be how I'd
played it in my head for the last
however many years they didn't disown me
they didn't go mad
they recognized I had a problem they
were glad I was still here and that I
needed help I was admitted to the rehab
for one of a better term I went to
treatment on Harley Street in London
um and those those few weeks months were
really really tough I like a lot of
people wanted a quick fix I thought oh
I'll go in now get treated I'll walk out
and I'll be cured but actually I had to
learn pretty quickly that this was
something that that doesn't just go away
it's something that I manage
essentially for the rest of my life the
process was was tough I had to sort of
come clean to people and having some of
those conversations particularly with
people I owed ludicrous amounts of money
to and had to admit that everything I'd
told them was complete rubbish and and
that actually it was gambling
was was so hard but
um people have been a lot quicker to
forgive me than I think I'll ever
forgive myself
did you kind of figure out how much
money you did spend on gambling over how
many years
yeah I had to go through I had to go
back through messages emails bank
statements
um gambling accounts I think it
transpires that over the course of those
12 and a half years I'd I'd transacted
um about two million pounds worth of
bets online
which was frightening in itself the
volume of bets the amount of bets I was
placing every day was was mad I had 76
different online accounts opened up in
65 different people's names so just just
the the sheer scale of of everything was
just Way Beyond what even I thought it
was and and in my head it was pretty big
ultimately nobody should go through what
I did and I often say to people I'm one
of the lucky ones because I'm still here
um too many lives are lost to gambling
um every year and that just can't happen
and you now do a lot of campaign work to
help people struggling with addiction
what does it entail so I now work full
time for a kind of organization that
specialize in education and prevention
we use our lived experience to try and
raise awareness of the problem educate
people about the dangers and pitfalls
reduce the stigma help people kind of
spot signs in themselves and other
people
do you have any advice you'd like to
give to someone who thinks they might be
addicted to gambling
understand that it's very easy to lose
control very quickly and the sooner you
can recognize that that you've lost
control
and do something about it the better
I have an issue with the fact that
gambling is is so ingrained in culture
and society and yet still a bit of a
dirty word
um it's still something that that people
don't talk openly about people only ever
talk about when they win never when they
lose
it's often something that that people
almost shame feel ashamed to admit that
they do I think I would have found it
much easier to talk about a problem with
drugs and alcohol and gambling that in
itself is is not right so reaching out
for help is tough but tell someone
um it'll be the best thing you ever do
one of the things I had to learn over
and above everything else was that it
was about managing this for the rest of
my life
um and I now am able to do that
um every day that goes past I feel like
I'm further away from a bet which can
only be a good thing
[Music]
yeah I met up with someone I knew I'm
not going to say friend you know like an
associate
a substance that I guess straight away
was heroin was put on the foil
and I was showing how to smoke that